vraiment sûr de la formation ce qui vous
intéresse et rejoindre les armées et
puis servir de servir la nation protéger
son pays et défendre les valeurs de la
république
kevin y pense déjà depuis trois ou
quatre ans les attentats de vendredi ont
été pour lui un déclic
à 21 ans il envisage de s'engager et de
faire carrière dans l'armée je toujours
se relever que dès que j'avais envie
d'aider est forcément avec casque s'est
passé ça donne encore plus envie de se
battre pour pour les gens qu'on aime
pour pour tout ce que dans son entourage
pour son pays
donc oui forcément ça va ça m'arrivait
quelque chose en plus depuis les
attaques terroristes de paris le site de
l'armée terre croule sous les
candidatures spontanées des volontaires
qui affluent dans les différents centres
d'information et de recrutement des
forces armées
du jamais vu pour le capitaine frémont
en poste à tour depuis trois ans et demi
on fonctionne beaucoup à 90 par rapport
à des candidatures internet les jeunes
aujourd'hui facebook où l'outil internet
donc on a à peu près 50 % de demandes en
plus de demandes d'informations en plus
depuis vendredi soir l'armée terre n'est
pas la seule concernée puisque la marine
et l'armée de l'air ont elles vu leur
demande augmenter de 30 à 40% depuis
samedi les profils de ces nouveaux
candidats dont la fibre patriotique
s'est réveillé les 7 janvier et 13
novembre dernier sont très variées mais
l'armée insiste néanmoins sur le fait
que tout profil est intéressant
l'économie sociale sur un bateau c'est
patrouille
ce qu'on recherche au départ est ce que
vous vous serez capable de vous adapter
finalement à la navigation par exemple
parce que l'officier de marine chez nous
sur un navire
passerait il participe à la mairie
gassion ça m'intéresserait aussi de
savoir comment ça se passe sur le
terrain de vivre mais avec les études
que j'ai fait je me dis que peut aussi
aider dans le dragon le renseignement
août comme ça donc du coup j'ai pas
vraiment fermé mais tant que je tends je
peux aider moi ce qui m'importe
depuis les attaques du bataclan françois
hollande a décidé de conserver tous les
effectifs de la défense l'armée terre
notamment devrait passer à 16000
recrutement en 2016